Joey is with us Joey is in Colorado hi
Joey how are you hey Dave doing well how
are you doing better than I deserve
what's up I want to just thank you for
all you've done over the years I've
benefited a lot from your work and
wanted to give a quick shout out to
everyone watching on YouTube they
encouraged me to make the call so my
question is related to how a small
business can prepare for a possible
recession so a little bit of background
on the leader of a 40-person small
business and we've been paying attention
to what's happening in the world how
people are freaking out about the
coronavirus I agree with your assessment
of it I think everyone's overreacting
you know the news is feeding us fear but
at the same time it is going to have an
impact on the economy I'm seeing what's
going on in Italy and so we're trying to
be pre-emptive and think ahead how we
can prepare for this a little bit about
the company we don't have any debt we
have six plus months of emergency fund
we sell digital products we're not
relying on in China we our client is a
multi-family apartment industry
wonderful entire our entire team works
from home we offer our team smart dollar
because I'm not just concerned about the
business but my team members as well
we're all access members for our area
leadership so we really bought into
everything you do so my question is how
did you prepare for and navigate the
2008 recession so that we can learn from
you in SOL suit thank you very nice
question well thought out exactly what
you did out of debt and a pile of cash
and I'm looking at my business lines and
saying okay where are we going to take a
hit where's revenue going to drop and
and do I need to repurpose some people
into different things you have one
product line don't we we have multiple
products we sell like floor plans
virtual tours and sitemap you sell
anything regular Zoomers at all
wholesale end of the business property
managers are so forth property managers
that are going after they use it in
their marketing material to attract and
engage prospects who might want to rent
from their property yeah unless they
quit doing that you're
not gonna have a problem now you know
what we thought actually you know when I
look we look back and I've talked about
this in entree leadership before we look
back on a we thought from a business
perspective that we were helping people
who were struggling with money and if
there was a recession more people would
be struggling with money so our business
would go up what happened was the
opposite of that our direct-to-consumer
like Financial Peace University sales
went down as a matter of fact it's the
only year in our history the sales went
down every year financial university
sales have gone up every single year in
home for almost 30 years
but that year they went down so it turns
out that even though people were
struggling with money they didn't want
the help from it they just wanted to be
afraid and not and didn't you know they
quit buying and they quit giving to
churches and and quit doing so forth so
you know we went through about a six or
an eight month downturn in revenue it
was not so severe that we actually
didn't make a profit in that area we
still were profitable we just didn't
have the year-over-year growth that we
had had before so it's more just
emotionally painful than actually
mathematically painful but we had enough
again we're sitting on a pile of cash
like you are and we had no debt and so
really it's just a matter of how much
money I'm gonna make not whether I'm
gonna lose money and not whether I'm
gonna lose enough money that I end up
having to be in position that I have to
let some people go because it can't make
payroll and I run out of that cash so
that's what you've just got to do is
just continually watch the market and so
forth so you know we are full steam
ahead here right now with live events
we've not cancelled a single one with
the Ramsey cruise we're not cancelling
it it's actually not up to us to cancel
it it's Holland America's cruise were
just the marketing arm on it we don't
have control of it technically so if
they cancel it we won't go but otherwise
we're going and so but you know it would
cause two reasons one is I'm not in
control of the decision to cancel it and
make refunds to tie 2,000 people but the
other thing is
I think it's ridiculous I think it's
completely over oil and so I'm shaking
hands and hugging necks
everywhere I go at every break and I
wash my hands a little more and I'm
gonna live my life and so it's more of a
business philosophy and a personal
philosophy too because I think these
people have gone completely bananas it's
just nuts and I may die from it because
of it I don't know but I'm not gonna
stop because I don't live in fear fear
is not a fruit of the Spirit hey thanks
for the call